foreign
hello and welcome to the view from 22
I'm Gus Carter The Spectators Deputy
features editor and I'm joined today by
John Sturgis a regular writer for The
Spectator online and spectator life last
week he wrote an excellent piece about
Russell Brand and his Fall From Grace it
went kind of viral and John's with me
now
John you wrote This brilliant piece can
you tell me how did Russell Brand go
from left-wing Firebrand to right-wing
conspiracy theorist well essentially it
was uh My article was predicated on the
piece that was in the guardian by George
mumbi at the um environmental writer he
had uh got right behind Russell Brand
about 10 years ago when he first was
taken up by the guardian and he at one
point described him as uh the best thing
to happen to the left for years he
nominated him as the his hero of the
year in 2014 and so roll forward 10
years and he then feels the need to uh
write this mayor Culper saying uh I was
wrong about Russell but in fact uh he he
then more or less says that Russell's
evolved into it in the wrong direction
rather than that he ever got it wrong my
take on it was that Russell Brown was
always a bit of a liability and was
hiding in plain sight as uh someone that
shouldn't be taken up seriously by
anyone left or right and that he was a
self-published and uh and a bit of a
charlatan that was always been my
position and I I've followed his career
in the UK stages I followed it quite
closely and noted a lot of these things
at the time that they were happening so
I was
um quite struck by the fact that there'd
been this kind of 10-year cycle where he
starts out as a sort of Champion
championed by the guardian and Ten Years
Later he's denounced by them so so can
you tell us a little bit more about what
George mombio kind of claims about
Russell Brand because I think I've just
I've just gone back and read the piece I
think he says something along the lines
of you know brand was was formerly a
kind of left-wing Firebrand uh and is
now kind of slid into slid into kind of
conspiracy theories do you think that's
that's quite right
well I'm I'm uh he he claims in that
piece to have watched 50 of his YouTube
videos which is a good number more than
I can claim to what I've got to be
honest so I I'm not fully conversant
with his daily over but he's got a very
big following he's got I think six
million subscribers on YouTube he
typically gets 300 000 views when he
puts something out he's got a lot you
know there's a lot of numbers there and
he is you know going to these um
subjects that seem to tickle a certain
sector of the online community there's
lots of stuff
um about the pandemic and about the
police thereof there's stuff about
global Elites and the stuff about media
conspiracies and so on so yeah I mean
that from from the guardian point of
view I think this was all stuff that's
moving towards him being closer to the
right than the left
um and that's why they they're you know
they I think Mom get describes him as
being uh you know a sort of fascist
enabler if not a fascist himself than
someone who's uh gate posting people
towards that kind of mindset and is
therefore uh becoming dangerous that was
the gist of what he was saying
um he certainly he's certainly got a big
following as I found out when my piece
was quite widely picked up in in the US
in particular and I got some uh some
very uh
a strong strongly worded critiques of my
piece from his fan club of whom there
seemed to be many thousands
um so he clearly has
um got a platform in the U.S that's
that's you know where he's become a very
popular figure among certain people and
they do seem to be quite valuable and
quite uh impassioned uh around some of
these issues that that he's you know
pushing promoting all the time but as
well as these kind of the economic and
the medical stuff there's also some kind
of really wacky stuff there's UFOs and
and stuff like that he's also he's still
doing the spiritual stuff so he's got
this kind of he's got kind of Route into
the U.S Christian right as well talking
about uh you know he's he's been 20
years cleaned the last couple of months
he's been celebrating that and talking
about spiritual journey and stuff so
that all resonates with that particular
sector of the U.S right-wing community
so he's kind of he has you know in some
ways at least his audience has moved
quite strongly from left to right over
the last 10 years it's a strange Journey
he's been on I think I think one of the
things mombio says in the in the article
is that is that the shift into a kind of
a conspiracy theorist mindset is is
evidence of a of a kind of inherent
right-wing turn
but but as you said there he talks a lot
about things like Global Elites which to
me is has always been a kind of
traditional kind of left-wing framework
a kind of left-wing way of thinking
about the world I mean certainly
conservatism in the in the UK is a lot
more kind of institutional uh than than
kind of conservatism is in in in America
do you think do you think that's right
that kind of conspiracy theories are are
always inherently something that's
that's right-wing
well that's certainly what mambio says
and I don't know that I'd necessarily
agree with him I think that that there
are um uh conspiracy theories that
appeal to both Wings in different ways
and and sometimes they join together the
extremes of left and right come together
on certain issues and seem to uh seem to
find common ground in in especially
around the pandemic there were there
were points where they were coming
together and you get the sort of Pierce
corbins joining in with the you know the
the far right it's a strange it's a
strange uh Melting Pot all of that I'm
not sure I mean brand himself I would
think would describe himself as neither
left nor right and just intellectually
curious and following his ideas wherever
they go that's certainly how he
um paints himself uh the the guardian
obviously now feel that he's a he's a
solidly right-wing figure and thus is
unsavory and to be avoided
um I think it's probably a bit more
complicated than that
um and in a sense Brand's right he he he
does say whatever he wants whatever he
finds interesting and follows whatever
it is I'm just not sure that he's very
reliable as a as a commentator and and
so in that sense I agree with the
Guardians thesis that he should be
avoided but then I always felt that when
they were championing him so that's kind
of where I I come into it is don't don't
denounce Russell Brand because of what
he's become denouncing because of what
he's always been and continues to be
which is is a self-promoting charlatan I
think in a way he's he's kind of
evidence of of of the fact that a lot of
these conspiracy theories don't really
exist in a in a left versus right
framework I mean if you look at the
people that brand as has endorsed over
the last few years he still claims to be
a Bernie Sanders supporter and yet also
seems to prefer Donald Trump to Joe
Biden it's it's kind of totally all over
the place isn't it yes I think I read
somewhere he likes Trump for his
virility which seems I suppose if you're
Russell Brown that's a that's an
attribute that you would find attractive
and and you know something worth uh
commenting on positively I he's he's a
strange guy and yes he does seem to
prefer Trump to Biden but still likes
Bernie Sanders where does that all hang
together I don't know I don't know if
there is any intellectual coherence here
I think a lot of it is kind of tub
thumping for the sake of uh the the
audience who who lap it up rather than
because it's a considered position that
has any intellectual Integrity or
ultimate meaningfulness now John I I
think I'm right in saying that you're a
former a former tabloid hack uh did you
ever have did you ever have any kind of
personal run-ins with Russell Brand
uh well there was one particular story
which I better not go into in too much
detail but it was between the jamai
McCann relationship and the Katy Perry
marriage he
uh took up with a young woman there was
a sun story about that and he got quite
deep into legal action on the question
of uh not whether he'd consulted with
this woman but whether he consulted with
this woman at the time that he was said
to have done so I did he two-time his
then girlfriend and he wrote in in the
garden he wrote a long denunciation of
the the story
um and then I don't think the legal
action ever LED anywhere so I think it
remains unresolved I suspect that his
position would continue to be that uh he
you know he'd acted with Integrity
throughout and but it was never it was
never tested in a full legal case so
that's the closest I ever came to
running because I had some involvement
in that process but my recollection of
him was was uh in a more personal way
was in um his earlier Incarnation before
the whole Guardian thing happened for
him before he became championed by them
he was he was a previously championed by
the sun uh he he famously was described
as the shagger of the year can we say
that on this show
he was he was described in those terms
and he did uh Revel in it it wasn't
something that it wasn't it it was very
much the case that he um was you know
playing to playing to type and uh I
think he accepted the award from memory
and you know he's probably had his place
on his mantelpiece at the time he he was
you know one minute he was sort of you
know being a clown for the Sun and then
he was very soon after that he was
denouncing the Sun and appearing to be a
serious character in the guardian and
now he's been denounced by the guardian
has moved towards the
um us-based Conspiracy set so he
certainly he he doesn't stay in any one
place he's obviously a very driven man
he's got bundles of energy I think if
one could
say anything positive about Russell is
that he's he's endlessly uh energetic
and constantly on the move and it you
know I can only uh applaud him for the
the energy levels that he has but
whether they're going anywhere positive
I don't know
I think I think that in a way is kind of
one of the great kind of admirable
elements of Russell Brand's character
this kind of extraordinary you know this
kind of extraordinary veracity his his
kind of ability to just grab things and
and kind of go for it but but you kind
of hit on something interesting there
earlier way where you said that that in
a way he was you know he was loading it
up as like top shagger of the year but
then also has this kind of strong kind
of self-taught intellectual element to
him do you think do you think these two
things have have kind of collided and
and taken him you know to this slightly
weirder weirder part of the internet
part of our culture
I think that that sort of auto-didact
thing is is a very strong part of what
what his makeup is I think I read an
interview with him some type in the sort
of Sundays when he talked about uh how
he you know wasn't particularly well
read but had got the idea that he could
sort of pick up the idea of books and
take on them I think obviously since
then he probably has read a good deal
and uh as sort of Cherry Picked his way
through some sort of Russell Brand
Cannon of what the significant uh
thinkers are and so on and he he's he's
kind of constructed this
um uh Russell Brand ideology and this
Russell Brand self out of this kind of
you know disparate uh selection of stuff
that he's come across whether it amounts
to much I'm not entirely convinced but
um it's yeah as it's he certainly is
driven by uh you know he he clearly did
um have a drug problem at one point and
did give it up and has in its place got
this kind of mad energy to do what he
does which is not always the same thing
it evolves but it's the one constant in
all of it is that is that he here he is
with his kind of hair and his jewelry
and his beard and his kind of crazy
energy being Russell Brand that's the
one constant in the whole thing the the
the fact that you know did he did he
endorse you know Ed miliband in 2015
does he sort of hint at supporting
trumpet seven or eight years later the
one consonant is Russell Brands there
showing off and being this kind of
Larger than Life character totally I
mean I've got a theory that I think
there's something almost in the in the
comedian's mindset the way that they
approach the world that makes them kind
of obsessive you know part of the way
that you make a joke is you take
something to its to its absurd
conclusion you can look at someone like
Graham Graham Linehan who's who's become
very involved in the in the trans
movement to the point where you know he
was in the papers over the weekend
saying it's damaged his personal life
it's damaged his his career do you think
there's do you think there's kind of
something something in that
well I think that there's I draw a
distinction between the two types the
the lineup has become obsessed with with
this one single issue which uh he by his
own account is allowed to destroy his
life and and to take over everything
else whereas bran seems to pick up and
put down issues at will and it has got
there's no constant attachment between
any one thing uh so there is a
similarity there in the sense that
they're both kind of uh out there doing
you know arguably demented stuff but um
Brands doesn't seem to be uh attached to
anything permanently his his only thing
is being Russell Brand that's his that's
the one constant the rest is is is is
just trappings
um so I think there's a there's quite a
big distinction between those two points
for me I mean you mentioned earlier that
that you thought there was a kind of
kind of semi-spiritual element in a way
to in a way to Russell Brand where do
you think that's that's come from
well I mean I I've seen him talk about
the spirituality in relation to the uh
recovery as a former addict and talk
about spirituality as a kind of means of
staying clean and I I think that that's
you know that that kind of goes to the
heart of
um a lot of the Alcoholics Anonymous
stuff the the the the the culture of
that world I think that it's not unusual
to to replace drugs or alcohol with with
spirituality and a quest for meaning and
so on um and it probably is quite a
useful tool if if you're in the grip of
that kind of addiction
um his seems to be uh a little bit he I
think he's always
um he's had an attraction for that kind
of you know he wants him he's he's a
kind of rock star without playing a
guitar he wants to have that kind of
image and I think he's he Cherry picks
different images and and ideas from
different times and places and and
references and one of the ones that he
he liked is that kind of
drug idled but also kind of you know
mystical 60s rock star in the vein of
the kind of late period Beetle and I
think that that's he perhaps it you know
he starts out posturing and then starts
to take it seriously and becomes uh
sucked into this uh to some of the ideas
that they're this kind of mystical
mindset I I I'm certain that he when
he's in in the grip of these things he
takes him seriously himself but just
from watching from a distance I'm not
sure that I can take him seriously
because it feels to me like it's an act
that he starts to believe in rather than
the genuinely sincerely held you uh look
although I say I suspect that he thinks
it's for real I'm just not sure that it
is it's it's funny that you mentioned
the idea of a kind of a kind of rock
star without a guitar because in a way
you can see how his career has almost
has almost followed that that kind of
Arc and if you look at people like Bowie
who had a kind of serious heroin
addiction at some point and if you look
at someone like Eric Clapton who who
fell in with the the the the national
front I think it was uh these people do
kind of come back and they do manage to
find themselves kind of back in a
position of being a bit of a National
Treasure do you think that could happen
with brand
I I don't I wouldn't rule anything out
with Russell Brown because he never know
what he's gonna do next
um I think he seems to have I I don't
even remember he had this brief period
where he tried to conquer America as a
film star in the mid late uh 2000s he
did a couple of rom-coms and one of them
he played a rock star you know that get
me to the Greek he was a he was a you
know kind of playing the character that
we're describing
um he then that really didn't play out I
don't think any of them were big were
big hits and he kind of came back to the
UK which is when the the whole I'm going
to save the left wing in the UK period
came along then he got bored with that
he transitions via I don't know if you
call he did it he did a show in his Shaw
ditch days he's set up a kind of oh you
can't rely on the mainstream media
they're all so you know they're telling
lies so we're going to tell the real
news the True News and call it the
truths oh yeah and then Joanne Harry is
who was the most discredited journalist
in the UK at the time was his kind of
researcher editor didn't Bode very well
and that was the sort of transition into
this relaunch in America so having not
quite made it as a rom-com style first
time out never having been a rockstar
just haven't played one he's now back to
he's now back in this kind of Joe Rogan
I'm a shock jock I'm a big YouTuber
thing and he does seem to have some take
up there and it does seem to be growing
so who knows will he will he come back
to the UK and have another go here is it
British person curiously if I was
talking to a friend of mine this weekend
in the wake of the Russell Brand she
lives very near him in uh he lives in
quite a nice area just outside Henley on
the river and she says locally he's like
a he's like you know one of those old
Showbiz characters like a Ronnie Corbett
or something he opens Fates and stuff
and turns up and he's all very nice and
and
uh you know just what you want from your
local celebrity in Henley and then he
kind of goes to the US and he's kind of
this bad you know trumpist you know
coronavirus conspiracist it's it's a
strange uh
twin uh character that he reconciles in
himself I don't know how he does it now
so I have no way of predicting what he
will do next he's a very strange man I
suspect that there will be a third
fourth fifth act for Russell Brand I
just don't know what it'll be I'm
looking forward to it I mean I mean I
really can't wait John thank you very
much for joining us on the view from 22.
foreign
[Music]